encuentra un trabajo que te guste y no
tendrás que trabajar ni un solo día de
tu vida
confucio lo dijo hace muchísimo tiempo y
nuestra generación la generación
emprendedores se lo está tomando más que
a pecho desde luego estoy convencida de
que todos conocéis algún emprendedor
apasionado o simplemente a un trabajador
apasionado de esos que se levantan todos
los días con ganas de sacar su proyecto
adelante de cumplir sus objetivos a los
que no les importa quedarse trabajando
hasta las tantas de la noche o incluso
los fines de semana porque tienen algo
en lo que creen y ese algo sea una idea
sea un proyecto sea una pequeña empresa
tecnológica que acaban de formar ese
algo les apasiona
es inspirador ver a tantísima gente
joven dispuesta a luchar por lo que
quiere dispuesta también a aportar su
granito de arena a las necesidades de la
vida moderna y del mercado laboral
y siempre sin quejas con entusiasmo con
una sonrisa en los labios sobre todo
anteponiéndose a los obstáculos del
camino con pasión pasión y más pasión
el problema es que muchas veces no nos
damos cuenta de que toda esa pasión
también les convierte en personas
vulnerables el valor positivo del
trabajo duro y del esfuerzo han estado
totalmente presentes a lo largo de la
historia más reciente de la humanidad
nuestros padres y nuestros abuelos lo
conocen bien pero hay algo que ha
cambiado y es que la frase hecha
trabajar para vivir y no vivir para
trabajar tiene una moraleja muy clara
que se asumía con total naturalidad
hasta hace más bien poco de tal forma
que podríamos resumir el razonamiento
tradicional de la siguiente manera
encuentra un trabajo en el que vayas a
poder esforzarte mucho y con ese
esfuerzo conseguirás un mejor futuro
para ti y para tu familia eso no excluía
la vocación los sueños profesionales
para aquellos primero pocos y luego cada
vez más afortunados que tenían la opción
de elegir una profesión acorde con sus
gustos pero en la mayoría de los casos
el fin último era el bienestar la
tranquilidad esa felicidad con los cinco
millas
y entonces qué es lo que ha cambiado
pues precisamente ese fin último que
ahora en muchas ocasiones se confunde
con el propio trabajo porque tu trabajo
es tu pasión es tu sueño es tu vida que
más quieres a priori no necesariamente
suena mal pero no olvidemos como no
olvidan tantísimas empresas que un
trabajo que te apasiona también es un
trabajo por el que estás dispuesto a
hacer todas las horas extra que sean
necesarias por el que estás dispuesto a
dejar a un lado tus derechos laborales y
así no es infrecuente escuchar que el
emprendedor vive para trabajar y que eso
es algo más que positivo la palabra
hasta que nos gusta tanto ahora es
inspirador
deberíamos admirarlo e imitarlo
el problema es que con toda esta
competitividad con esta teoría del
emprendedor
estamos yendo casi un paso más adelante
de confucio pues confusión bueno no de
confucio estaría un mejor diría al
emprendedor le gusta tanto su trabajo
que no puede considerarse trabajo y si
no puede considerarse trabajo porque iba
a exigir un salario justo porque no iba
a renunciar a una conciliación efectiva
entre su vida profesional y su vida
laboral porque no iba a prestarse a la
explotación si trabaja para otros oa la
auto explotación si es como tanto nos
gusta decir últimamente su propio jefe
ahora bien por supuesto esta mentalidad
no es la causa de la precariedad laboral
que predomina en el mercado de empleo
joven sea un autónomo en nuestro país
sería muy simplista pensar esto porque
la precariedad ya existía el problema
por lo que respecta a la actitud que
estoy comentando es que legitima esa
precariedad y la idealista
convierte esfuerzos muchas veces
inhumanos en algo romántico por eso un
consultor juniors decide no reivindica
sus derechos laborales un joven médico
residente decide no exigir guardias
menos extensas
un joven o no tan joven artista decide
no solicitar una remuneración congruente
con todas las horas que ha invertido en
su trabajo porque habría de hacerlo
acaso no las ha disfrutado el arte no
era una pasión y eso sin tener en cuenta
el estrés y la presión que sufren todas
estas personas desde que eran
estudiantes es decir desde la época en
la que aprendieron que en un mundo de
apasionados en un mundo en el que si tú
no lo das todo otros 20 lo darán por ti
nada de lo que hagas será nunca
suficiente
fijaos simplemente en eventos como este
por supuesto hay muchísimas charlas
motivacionales sobre cómo emprender cómo
hacer realidad tus sueños y no hay otras
tantas sobre cómo no morir en el intento
sobre cómo hacer frente al estrés y a
los efectos negativos que tienes sobre
la salud y la vida profesional y tampoco
podemos quedarnos ahí porque a nivel
social y a nivel político
corremos el riesgo de pensar
que el crecimiento económico puro es el
fin primero de nuestros estados y no
solamente un instrumento para hacer
efectiva una mejor calidad de vida un
mayor bienestar social corremos el
riesgo de confundir competitividad con
renuncia a derechos y con explotación
corremos el riesgo de pensar que
emprender que la economía colaborativa o
que este primer empleo que tanta ilusión
te hace no son trabajos sino
oportunidades
y que precisamente por eso no merecen la
protección legal y social que recibirían
si fueran trabajos
llegados a este punto que podemos hacer
para dejar atrás esta perspectiva tan
sesgada y tan nociva
relativizar y hacer una llamada más que
urgente al egoísmo lo principal eres tú
tú como persona por supuesto como
persona que tiene vocación que tiene
sueños profesionales que tiene
inquietudes sí pero también como persona
que cuida de sí misma de su salud que se
preocupa por su familia por sus amigos
que tiene tiempo para disfrutar de ellos
como también tiene tiempo para leer para
ver series para pasear para disfrutar
pasárselo bien para aburrirse
tal vez simplemente necesitamos
redefinir el confucio del siglo 21 y
adaptarlo podría ser algo así
encuentra un trabajo que te guste
en el que se respeten tus derechos
laborales y en el que seas más persona
que trabajador y si trabajaras
muchísimos días de tu vida pero
trabajaras feliz muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]